Inside of your mouth are usually 32 teeth:
8 incisors, 4 canines, 8 premolars, 8 molars,
and 4 third molars.
One of these things is not like the other…
One of these things, doesn't belong!
Hey toothers
The third molars -- commonly called wisdom
teeth -- form as early as age 12 when tissue
sacs called follicles migrate to the soft
tissues in the back of your jaw to form buds.
If they do, they'll erupt from from the gum
line by age 25.
If you leave wisdom teeth in place, they can
become impacted, form cysts, get infected,
or weaken the bone of the jaw, which is why,
after the advent of anesthesia, dentists began
removing them.
But not everyone has the same experience!
Evolution has completely redrawn the boundaries
of the human head, and wisdom teeth got caught
in the crossfire.
But if there's no room for them, why do we
even have them?
100 million years ago, our ancestors' jaws
were large enough to make room for all 32
teeth -- and they were all useful, with molars
doing a lot of grinding and chewing of greens
and raw meats.
As we evolved, we didn't really need the big
strong back teeth anymore.
After the advent of cooking, food became easier
to digest and to chew; so again, having a
third set of molars was pretty useless.
As our ancestral primates took advantage of
these evolutionary wins, we began to walk
upright, grew larger brains, and developed
longer arms; yet, somehow our third molars
weren't entirely eliminated.
Thanks, Mr. Darwin.
That being said, 65 percent of people don't
develop wisdom teeth at all; and some will
only get one, two, or three.
In one study from University of Tennessee-Knoxville,
African-Americans, and Inuits tend to have
third molar agenesis, meaning they never develop
wisdom teeth buds.
In fact, Inuits, seem to hardly ever grow
wisdom teeth.
Alan Mann, an anthropologist from Princeton
University, believes this is because the Inuit
tend to have flatter faces and narrower jaws.
He believes as the brain got larger, there
was no more room in our faces, and the evolutionary
advantage went to those who didn't have these
superfluous, painful teeth.
Essentially, their own genetics caused natural
selection to weed out the Inuit who did grow
the teeth, as they'd likely experience the
medical difficulties associated with those
who grow them today, yet have no way to fix
it.
On top of that, research from the University
of Pennsylvania found a mutation in a gene
called MYH16, which resulted in the shrinking
of our jaw, further pushing out these stupid
teeth.
This process actually started hundreds of
thousands of years ago.
While doing research in China in 2011, Mann,
the Princeton anthropologist, found the oldest
known fossils without wisdom teeth, dating
from 300 to 400,000 years ago.
Experts think wisdom teeth are similar to
pinky toes or human tails -- they're vestigial
-- leftover bits in the ongoing process of
evolution.
So even though wisdom teeth started out as
something useful, today they are more a pain
than a perk!
If third molars do appear (and there's not
enough space on your jaw for them to fit)
the American Association of Oral and Maxillofacial
Surgeons, recommend they be removed.
Of course, in the end, the fate of this vestigial
evolutionary tooth it's a matter for you and
your dentist.
Life is weird.
TestTube now has a newsletter!
Get a weekly round-up of our most popular
videos across all our shows at